hello and welcome to this video playing
i am michael h it's mike lanigan right
just have a an intro but it's it's him
so i get my line here against the
English plate like this variation always
open for short castles giving me the h5
attack I will still do it misc why isn't
all that great just plus 1 against him
so why would you want to each one not a
happy move but so it's not so easy for
life
yeah i'm playing this quite quickly
because i recently analyzed it I felt
that this is good for okay how to play
you with black something if six prolly
just develop
isn't that good I might not get it back
so easily okay I'm sure that the bishop
was doing all that much anymore and that
be five Kevin bottom line is I probably
shouldn't have done that even 94 as a
movie oh ok a five look tempting
strategically but that didn't work out
so well nicely ass got many pieces on
the queenside maybe i should actually
take a five he's got night no no he
doesn't have an idea for I like him to
play 9 p-5 here get more pieces on the
queenside my idea is just Knight g4 and
heck on h4 this is dangerous very
dangerous if I again you know I kid okay
so he actually believes that yeah I'd
okay not a big problem he actually takes
with this pizza extra treats it
and yes great play ah my goodness okay I
completely blended the exchange no the
only thing is it's still not that easy
position is quite close and now g-49
takes h4 still a simple idea but
potentially quite a hectare now let's
see see how he fights this pretty much
going to do this no matter what
he doesn't seem to consider to be very
dangerous maybe it isn't
maybe you can just move the rock the f
rogue
in fact I'm taking on age who I mean it
gets all the pieces into the attack yeah
this is making lots of sense pushing or
letting this and yeah cutting this out
okay so if I take one h4 twice he will
move the rook what do i do at the end
Bishop f5 probably yeah it's not a big
decision let's do it I mean after
blundering the exchange of Coulomb and
who look down I like 42 pounds or
something I understand that he didn't
didn't want to take it but I think here
he should have objectively speaking okay
so takes it off do I have some other
trickery here probably not and now h4 h4
for a pawn to h3 yeah I'm not sure that
doesn't do all that much c6 the funky
idea here takes on d6 takes on d5 it
that gets actually gets me lots of
champagne and it's it's tricky I'm not
sure he wants to play you for here he
does this is opening up the position
quite quite quickly now or queen g5
actually maybe 25 it's a bit more active
I don't think this is it is a clear
situation now anymore it cannot easily
move the ce pas one as I will take on d3
and f2 probably very murky situation
okay so i can take here take f2 I just
want to ever have something better rook
c8 probably that looks better the Queen
doesn't have a good square really
it moves to be five I mean c3 Hanks and
especially form no I think even probably
a now too much them so I can takes you
three but you will take a play check
here yeah justice was the tempting move
anyway white forfeits on time hmm ok i
blundered the exchange but it did cut
practically not it wasn't easy take from
a practical point of view and a five is
a strategic or strategic i don't know
probably a mistake don't I don't get
this back as easily other thought okay
here the engine actually yeah I wants to
cancel and this is not terrible as as as
controlled by the computer ok I can
actually take already aha like
immediately that's funny yech okay he
currently is this a problem yet I
creates a choice on and if you move the
rook f2 is hanging so like this and the
f5 was winning wow yeah I mean it's me I
have many pieces here they all they all
participate somehow and why says stuff
on the queenside okay I wanted to
actually my idea was I mean I thought 94
was was stupid and I wanted to provoke
this like snatch the pawn and make him
displace this piece so that this could
be even more effective but I totally I
totally overlooked that
a thought attic here and I totally we
looked at the ruckus actually I mean you
can take it with this Bishop and removes
the bishop from the attack some great
stuff anyway I still had this
sacrificial idea and I think from a
practical point of view this is not so
easy why should probably win with best
play but doing that in the Blitz game
isn't easy I here could have taken
already gone wrong ok this is still this
is possible and the engine pretty
immediately recognizes that this is
playable and not suggest some kind of
gamble it's funny it's funny back here
yeah I mean it's a rock currently it's a
rook okay then I wasn't quite sure at
five was an f5 or Bishop f5 the engine
knows his Bishop f5 the thing is this
kind of thing here yeah he cannot move
this and I had f5 coming here they have
porn it's really not Kim I mean I kind
of had to do it and just hope that it
works but I had the feeling it might
work and the engine the engine confirms
that this is not objectively bad but I
think he has to go for it i mean here i
think im just bad on h4 yeah age from I
wasn't quite sure but I can actually
take I didn't consider to take opening
up the age five looked a little bit
crazy maybe it is crazy the engine takes
a moment directly not i but this cannot
be all that valium c6 maybe not
objectively best but it completely am it
was certainly irritating is this move
and yeah so I thought you would take and
then my attention was to take here Oh
7 hmm I got this but there's d7 I will
loop d7 and then okay the engine wants
to go Quinn g5 then this makes this six
idea a little bit weird yeah there are
some funny points here this for example
and 12 emanated irritated him probably a
lot no this is a winning attacker yeah
so winning attack I don't think young he
can be blamed their lot it's it was very
difficult to play this position and I
mean black is probably not in a good
shape objectively but it's easy if you
can always play those cannot see can
play those kind of attacking moves ok
guys thanks for watching